بينما تحتفل فيه موسكو بعيد النصر
الغتكييف احتفالات التاسع من مايو بسبب
الحرب الروسيه يوم اعتاد اوكرانيون احياءه
لعقود سابقه لكن الحرب غير ذلك
فالاحتفالات ولا عرض عسكري الى هنا حيث
النصب التذكاري والشعله التي لا تنطفئ
تعود الاوكرانيون ان ياتوا لاحياء ذكرى
الجنود المجهولين الذين قتلوا او قضوا في
الحرب على النازيه
جدايل اثنين قاتله في الحرب العالميه وابي
كان احد قاده المقاومه احد جديه توفي في
الحرب والاخر عاد حيا اخبروني كثيرا عن
ذلك هذه عائلتنا ونحن يجب ان نتذكر ذلك
والدي كان من جنود البحريه وقاتل وعاد حيا
من الحرب وكان يحترم هذا اليوم ويحتفل به
ونحن احببنا هذا اليوم ونتذكره دائما ومع
تواصل الحرب تتراجع الاحتفالات وي الحضور
الا من بعض من ذوي الضباط والجنود الذين
حاربوا النازيه في صفوف جيش الاتحاد
السوفيتي السابق هؤلاء يرفضون تغيير تاريخ
ذكرى الحرب من التاسعه الى الثامنه من
مايو بحسب مشروع قانون رئيس الذي قدمه
للبرلمان
احتفل بيوم النصر في التاسع من مايو رفقه
الحاضرين هنا يوم حرب اوروبا وتحريرها من
النازيه اما الثامن من مايو الذي يريد
رئيس نازيسكا ان يحتفل به فليحتفل به
لوحده كان شارع الخرشات وسط كييف يشهد
عرضا عسكريا في هذا اليوم الامر الذي يغيب
منذ اندلاع الحرب وكانت الذكرى يوما يحتفل
فيه جميع ابناء الشعب الاوكراني حتى داخل
بيوتهم الا ان الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا
انتزعته من نفوس الكثيرين ولم يتبقى الا
استصدار قانون تغيير تاريخ الذكرى عبر
البرلمان لتصبح الذكرى ذكريات عادل
العربيه كيف لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
وال برامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات